foreign
[Music]
Armstrong is among the most original
impactful and inclusive religious
historians and her best-selling books
have deeply influenced the global
conversation on the role of religion in
both the ancient and the modern worlds
here is my conversation with Karen
filmed at the New York Historical
Society exploring humankind's evolving
relationship with the Earth life and the
cosmos
[Music]
it really is great to see a live
audience something I haven't seen in a
long time
and Karen it's a it's a great honor for
me to spend some time speaking with you
tonight as someone who has read so many
of your books and you've really had a
profound influence on my own thinking
about so many things and one way of
framing the conversation tonight is in
terms of something that you've written
quite eloquently on that there are
different ways of knowing about the
world there's different kinds of
knowledge I come at it from physics yes
you know I try to understand things like
that you know but I I full well
understand that the knowledge that we've
gleaned over the course of scientific
history is not going to exhaust
everything that we can know about the
world so you described in terms of
Mythos and logos can you give us a sense
of that well logos is reason and that's
that's where you where you're good at
and uh but Mythos is also important too
but it's something that's got rather
displaced in in the modern world a myth
has been a I described as something that
in some sense happened once
but which also happens all the time
it's talking about Timeless truths very
often today we've become so rational in
the way we talk that what a myth means
something that's not true uh that it's
something you know it's a myth it didn't
happen but that was not the way that was
seen in the in ancient world everyone
knew that we had to have logos uh that's
your science that's your reason
uh but we also needed myth that helped
us to understand why things happen
um and the the more the emotional and uh
and difficult aspects of our life that
don't uh that that don't can't be
controlled by reason we all have uh
moments of uh awe and wonder fear and
Terror that reason can't touch it's
science can't touch it and in the and we
we want meaning in our lives
uh it we're meeting seeking creatures
and unless we have some kind of sense
that our lives have some meaning and
value or significance we fall very
easily into despair
and so myth helps us to counteract that
despair but would you say that there is
or or perhaps not
a fruitful notion of of Truth when it
comes to myth or is that sort of a
category error like am I asking whether
the table is happy or the number five is
married questions that just don't mean
anything does the question of Truth when
it comes to myth doesn't mean anything
yes it does because there are different
kinds of truths uh so you have your
scientific kind of Truth which is vital
for all of us and that's where logos
comes in but there are also truths about
human behavior
death that we all have to face and we we
TR we don't know how to deal with it uh
we we are beings that fall very easily
into despair
if we don't find some kind of meaning
and uh and sorrow and and why
why are we here what are we supposed to
be doing here
and that's where myths and religion
comes in and literature too which which
also helps to helps us to Grapple with
the feeling that uh Our Lives often seem
so pointless
uh and we can and insignificant
what are we here for what are we doing
how can we when we finally die say that
we've had done anything good for the
world
or uh how do we deal with the pain that
we see in the world
uh the suffering
uh how do we deal with death how do we
deal with inequality
uh Injustice
um and uh so all of these things that
are not easy easily answered yeah
but can I ask you a question of context
in there because
when I think about this categorization
of logos and and Mythos they're two
distinct ways that it plays out inside
my head one is I think about science as
something which in principle is giving
us Universal truths that are relevant
like way out there in the in the cosmos
whereas Mythos is deeply tied to the
Human Condition and when I think about
Earth as a little tiny pale blue dot
floating in the vast expansive space
it's like logos covers all of it yes and
Mythos is very tied to the human side
but at the same time I'm also willing to
say that our science is just the human
attempt to understand the world so maybe
they're just on equal footing from that
more limited perspective there may be
people out there who knows looking at us
with great pity
that neither of us are hitting the
market and have nothing to do with with
other kind means of reality that are
beyond our Ken yeah so so that but
nevertheless we're stuck with this uh
aren't we with this perception of being
here and now in this this troubled
Planet unlike other animals
uh we know that we're going to die
um and that has uh has that overshadows
our lives
uh and and what happens to us when we
die
how do we face the fact of our own
mortality
does the fact that we're just going to
die and disappear in the world mean that
our lives have no significance
because we do like meaning
and I don't think science can give us
that kind of meaning do you I mean well
it's an interesting yeah interesting
question because the fact that we know
that we're going to die
is something which in terms of its
relevance to the way we live our lives
something that I first really
encountered in a book called the denial
of death by Ernest Becker and when I
read that book back you know his early
20s it had a profound effect to me but
surprisingly when I spoke to other
people about it many would say I know
I'm going to die I I don't really think
about it doesn't bother me but in the
end that I think is really just the
power of culture the power of religion
the power of other things that allow us
to hide behind this gloss of not caring
when I agree with you that that we
deeply do and this is is vital in fact
you know Stephen J Gould said that all
religions begin with death they're
recognize is is that your yes I think
that's right I think that's true uh
because uh the fact that we are going to
die means we've got to try and make some
kind of Point see some kind of point
um and that we we have and it it
overshadows our lives and we see people
dying
um and and is is there is there any most
of the uh world religions begin with uh
why why death the Buddhism for example
sickness old age and death are what he
saw in life the Buddha how how do we
cope with this
and and of course sickness in the
pre-modern world would have been far
more uh extreme than it is today I mean
most children wouldn't often live to to
grow up
um and uh
illnesses could just wipe out wipe
people out so sickness old age and
deaths in the Buddha we've got to find
some other kind of way of dealing with
the with these realities that enable us
to use the lives that we have that the
time that we have productively
uh instead of just sitting in Terror or
else having when you come to die having
led a pointless life
and I think at their best the religions
uh the religions try to help us with
that they sometimes fail I mean I
remember as a as a school girl as a
Catholic school and we used to have
Retreats every year and
um the the
Jesuits would come and they all Jesuits
always begin with death
and so it was the first day was very
gloomy I mean uh there we were sort of
and they tell us terrible things you
know about a young boy who was sitting
you know thinking he was absolutely fine
and why should he worry and somebody uh
decided to pin a little uh a picture
over his over his bed well unfortunately
that hit a gas pipe and the child died
I've died that day when we were told
these stories and uh we were and usually
we went to bed in in fear and Gloom and
Terror wow uh but yes it was it was
wrong and I don't think it really helped
us very much
um so so would you say that that myth
which then develops presumably into the
world's religions
is it something that comes from us from
this unique self-aware Consciousness I
think or is it is it it does it maybe it
doesn't matter is it out there are we
touching something out there was it
purely something that's within us I
think it has to be something that is
within us
um because really we know nothing about
what's out there
um and the best myths don't give us a
lot of dogmatic truths about say reality
is called God for example uh they help
us to deal with the with with the
problems of life but in a myth in a in a
story that somehow makes sense
um and or to live in a way that does
somehow provide a sense of meaning
I mean in science do you find that
science helps you
to live a better life yeah it's a great
question and and for me the answer is
yes yes and and let me just spend 10
seconds saying why so I find that when I
understand the laws of quantum mechanics
that govern how molecules come together
to yield structures in the world I find
that when I understand the laws of
general relativity that allow the
universe to expand and stars to coalesce
out of particles and galaxies to
coalesce out of stars it gives me a
sense of connection to the universe and
it also gives me a deep sense of
gratitude
for the mere fact that a collection of
particles happen to coalesce into a
being that momentarily gave me a sense
of self-awareness and Consciousness that
allows me to appreciate the wonders of
reality and it is the scientific Insight
that to me lays bare all the processes
that allowed that to happen and that
enriches my sense of who I am and my
connection to the wider world
I wouldn't say that the answers all
questions though
I don't think that we we get answers to
these questions the religions try or
some of the religions try to tell you
that there is a an answer to this that
there that when you die for example you
will go to heaven for example or
um other religions such as Buddhism uh a
little more uh hesitant about this there
are uh there's a sense of reincarnation
that you'll you'll come back perhaps and
uh the jains for example say that if you
live a good good life you'll go up on on
the scale and human beings they say are
at the top of the scale but they also
say which and this is important that uh
this tiniest thing has some kind of
existence that we know nothing of that
each thing has its own form of existence
so a flower or a stone uh these if they
behave become really good stones and
flowers
um they will go up the scale and
gradually they too will arrive at
Humanity but human human beings can push
themselves right down by behaving in
without compassion and mercy the idea is
to somehow transcend the self that
selfishness
that puts me first all the time that
doesn't consider others which means
getting rid of the ego
uh which we we all cling to our sense of
self
there seems to be a lot of talk these
days about getting rid of the ego you
know you hear it in mindfulness training
in meditation in psychedelics that it's
a way of
ego dissolution
do you think that
if religion is in some sense a pathway
toward that
I always find it curious to then
juxtapose that with your comment before
about a potential afterlife which seems
like we're striving to preserve the ego
for all of eternity and pretty nice
living conditions as well that's it yes
I that that is what sort of turned me
off a lot of of religion in fact that
you're just looking for a sort of
comfortable role in in the hereafter
uh but that's at their best and I we
must sort of press that uh the religions
are telling us that you the best way of
uh
somehow achieving
uh and like is to get beyond the self
get beyond the ego
um and that one does that in not
necessarily in in not in yoga which not
everybody can do it's a very skillful
not not you'd know that sometimes by
what how people do yoga today
um very often yoga is seen as you know
sort of you come out and you're all
toned up and uh you know you you you you
you look into yourself and you feel
great the point about yoga as the Buddha
was to do it is to get rid of the ego by
reaching out to others
they would have achieved Enlightenment
by not by sort of going deeply into
himself and perfecting that self but by
sending out his compassion to every
corner of the world and not omitting a
single creature flower or human being
however ghastly they might be from his
area of concern and that I think is is
what uh we we need today
so much of our spirituality seems to be
with me me me and uh so sort of for my
peace of mind and my highly tuned body
uh as a result of all this yoga
um
uh but that's that's embedding you in
the ego that you're trying to transcend
and I think what the religions at their
best are trying to do is to help you do
that yeah but too often they're made a
sort of ego trip
um whereby you you you you you you
polish your own self and your own soul
and you're looking for a nice
comfortable role in heaven or but no
it's it that the the thing is and I
think we need this more in our culture
is to put the ego the selfishness to one
side uh day by day uh by uh and then you
start to expand
uh and uh I think so a lot of the the
myths at their best are telling us how
to do that so when you think about those
myths or even the stories in sacred
texts
there certainly are a substantial
fraction of people in the world who
would consider themselves Believers or
adherents who who interpret those
stories fairly literally and then you
have people who write books trying to
tear down religions by saying they're
not true and trying to make a rational
logical argument would you say that
that's a complete gross misreading of
the text that it's a more metaphorical
poetic and a course of action as opposed
to A Treatise on fundamental external
truths yes I mean it's not about reason
and any kind of myth that ends up in
sort of ego
uh is is a bad myth
uh the what the but a myth makes no
sense unless you put it into action
um it's not enough to tell and it's not
Justice it's not enough to just go to
church and sing a few hymns put
something in the collection box and then
go back to ordinary life and Sunday
lunch and uh and become and back to the
office and back to uh putting putting
number one first and and tramping down
others uh it's a process whereby you
leave the self behind I mean in science
do you leave the self behind well when
confronted with the big truth of the
universe you certainly do feel that your
individuality doesn't matter yes
if Einstein hadn't discovered general
relativity David Hilbert would have and
the fundamental truths the equation Army
knew managed to have Jimmy no articles 8
Pi g receded 14 you know that would be
the same equation regardless of who
discovered it so in that sense you are
leaving the the self behind but
scientists like everybody else get
deeply embedded in the work and they
identify themselves with the work you
know Ludwig boltzmann who committed
suicide on his Tombstone car had carved
s equals K log W his equation for
entropy yes you know so so his ego was
deeply tied up yes you know with that
deep inside of the world yes uh but yes
but a lot of religion you see is is is
is about sort of getting into heaven and
getting a good place there and uh and
that's all about me
um so again uh that the vote in both
ways like was there a transition
historical transition that one can
follow where religion went from a more
metaphorical poetic interpretive schema
to a more literal one yes it happens in
Europe
in the 16th century in the universities
uh people the students studied Aristotle
before they studied religion
and that means they bought Aristotelian
science and logic and put brought it to
Bear upon
um upon reality so Thomas Aquinas who
lived long before that uh says is is
quite clear that God for example is
everywhere and wherever God is God is in
their holy uh but by the time they've
thought got taken it through Aristotle
God has been uh confined to a tiny part
of the universe like heaven like heaven
that he is supposedly created and uh the
and now it's up and and people are
saying look looking at the scriptures in
a different way so Roger Bacon in the
16th century says well now
um Adam was told by God take the Earth
and subdue it
and Adam
failed to do this and that's why he fell
from Grace
so it's now up to us to take the Earth
and subdue it and that's what we've been
doing
with the result that we now have a very
very damaged Universe a very very
damaged world
when we are in great Peril because of
this
so whereas the other world religions had
an entirely different view of God
uh it's God wasn't something up there
when the it's a lovely story the when
the Jesuit missionaries in the 17th
century uh went across to China
um they became part of the Confucian
Literati they wore Chinese clothes they
spoke Chinese and they brought with them
the new science that we developed uh
that caused Great problems of course in
in Europe because Galileo and Copernicus
it didn't seem to gel with the theology
but the confusions found that all very
interesting they loved it
but says one of them when they start
talking about egg God
confined to a tiny portion of the
universe in a heaven that he a universe
that he supposedly created really they
said this this is this is ridiculous and
what the what is interesting is that
both China and India
um thousands of miles apart developed a
far different consensus conception of
nature
whether sacred is present in a force
throughout all things
there's no there's no single God but
there is such sacrality uh uh uh in all
things we went on and on confining God
In A peculiar way uh which has made God
for many people incomprehensible has
your own
journey and view of God under God I
presume radical change when you were 17
years old you entered the convent yes
for seven years I gather you stayed if
you reflect back on your 17 year old
self's view of God compared to where you
are now what what is that transformation
oh entirely different
there's a God up there a human a sort of
a human being writ large who is kind of
looking at me and but unfortunately
they're seeing all my faults
and um and my job is to get rid of those
faults uh so that I become holy and and
wise and uh but uh but they did that by
it was not a very healthy way of doing
things we were continually being told uh
to uh to to to to to how sinful we were
um and we are constantly kissing the
ground and uh sort of pray trying to
pray and I could not pray this was a bit
of a as you say that was clearly a
rather a drawback for a nun
um because I would we had to pray in a
certain way making certain meditations I
could not do it I can concentrate on my
studies for hours at a time without you
know lifting my head but every morning
we had to
meditate according to Saint Ignatius if
the nation says uh precepts he was the
founder of the Jesuit order
and I just could not do because your
mind would wander absolutely it just
went off into a complete tangent I
couldn't control it
I mean and um so and I kept on saying
that I really can't do this oh no sister
we all have bad days I'd have loved to
have had some some bad days because it
would mean some would be good but but
that never happened
um and eventually I I left in and I went
right away from religion I wanted
nothing whatever to do with it again
nothing at all and what brought you back
well it's a strange thing as I kept on
trying to get away from religion
and I wanted to be an English literature
teacher and um but in a university
because and I did a PhD
and
um I failed it
and there was it was a quite a scandal
at Oxford at that time because the
examiner had said I was a very clever
young woman but in his view this was not
a suitable subject for a PhD in four
lines
uh and the he was told that you were
supposed to write a very detailed but it
was already approved presumably your
your topic yes oh you didn't mention it
um and he was told he would never be
invited to examine for Oxford again but
then what do they do with Miss Armstrong
well they decided they they were worried
about this for six months with me and
misery as you can imagine and decided I
couldn't have it that the Injustice was
being done but that if they allowed for
a re-examination it would destroy the
sanctity of the Oxford doctorate
so that was the end of my academic
career huh can I give you one small
footnote my doctorate at Oxford was also
rejected read a different story but uh
really yeah it was corrected ultimately
but just so you know
well here we are today yeah exactly
to heck without yeah absolutely
um but but so you go on this this
journey that ultimately brings you back
and I hope this doesn't sound like a
facile question but
what does God mean to you now
certainly not a being
uh in this the highest heaven
um
I I just think that the sacrality is in
all of us
every single one of us has a sacred call
there's something sacred in all of us
that's and the Buddhists and Indians do
people of India do this when they hold
the and they bow to one another each one
of us just as every single uh inanimate
thing
in the planet has some kind of
wonder about it
animals for example two uh each animal
is is is I I find quite precious
and extraordinary in in its life and we
too and I think that one tries to cut I
can try to cultivate a sense of
sacrality
in other people
uh a sense of uh Divinity in other
people but one does that by not by doing
vast spiritual exercises but by I think
by by treating other people
with utter respect
so that each person that you you you you
encounter is somehow sacred but that
doesn't mean I don't think that that
means that we're then going up I don't
believe anymore in a God in the heavens
and I don't believe that when I die I
will go up to join him
um do you have a sense of what will
happen when you die no is that it no I
have no idea do you
I think it's it yeah yeah I just think
my particles will dissolve and rejoin
the particles of the cosmos and that
will be that and momentarily I was here
and then I'll be gone but I've been
lucky to have this life yes I deeply
agree yes with exactly that statement
and one of the other
connections to this perspective which
you you focus attention on in your
latest book is that it's this reverence
for everything
that we need to reconnect with in order
to survive as a as a species and we've
lost we've lost it now in every other uh
religious uh discipline in in ever in
every other part of the world in China
in India they have much the same idea of
the Divine in all things in all that
that doesn't mean it's God just get
there is no God gods are part of they
see Gods as part of the universe that
they're created by this Force
um and they're but they're present in
all things so that it there's a Divinity
in all things so
um that you and that's I think is what
we have a sense to cultivate
to look at one another however I'm
promising the exterior reality is
and see somehow that realize that in
some sense there's a sense of this of
the of the Sacred in that but not just
in people
but in animals uh in in in in in in
nature which is what what all the world
religions had no idea of a God in the
heavens god what the sacred was
everywhere
everywhere and the one live one that
what we had to do was look beneath the
unpromising exterior to the sacrality
within and that means treating other
people and and nature
with absolute respect with absolute uh
reverence and so what I've tried to do
is show in my book show how we can
cultivate this because we we are in such
uh we have such awful we develop such
awful habits
of just an ill-treating nature and we're
still doing it we keep hearing about how
uh terrible the planet is and what
danger we're in and certainly I know in
I I don't know how it's been here but in
the UK temperatures reach absolutely as
uh unprecedented Heights sure and one of
the points you make is that and and
you've made reference to it here as well
that more of the Eastern religions that
that
reverence for nature may have been more
present in those perspectives on the
world compared to say Jewish tradition
Christian
uh monotheism is different from every
other world religion
uh because instead of seeing the sacred
as a force in nature
not a God in the sky but that that
everything in nature is sacred
uh they developed an idea of a god a
single God in the heavens
um who created everything but they saw
uh the sacredness not in nature but in
historical events in The Exodus from
Egypt for example sure or or the life of
Jesus Christ
interestingly though the Greek Orthodox
retained their Pagan view of Nature and
that and brought it into Christianity
because for them Artemis the god that
goddess of nature one of the most
revered of all the Greek goddesses they
say she was present uh invisibly in
every single plant every single bird
every single blade of grass
um and they they have retained that and
similarly interestingly Islam
uh sees which sees nature
as an absolute miracle that is uh
compared that is just as important to
Revelation as the Quran itself now
that's extraordinary when you think that
this was hap this was conceived in Saudi
Arabia what is now Saudi Arabia with
this hideous climate with uh the the
Arabs in the seventh century were all up
suffering from malnutrition because the
the Earth the the the the climate could
not allow them to buy grown up food
but they see that at the Quran you have
to understand it uh it's no good reading
it and people say I've read the Quran
it's rubbish and boring you have to hear
it and it's chanted it's sung and uh
that it's it's like reading the libretto
of an opera uh you you don't get it
unless you hear that hear the chant and
so this this
has a courage a sense of beauty of
nature but instead of focusing as we as
the Christians and Jews do on Miracles
which subvert the natural order the
Quran celebrates the the at Justice all
the pre
uh ancient religions did then the fact
that the Divine is present in the
ordinary nature of things the fact that
the sun rises every day
and that the moon comes up at night and
that uh there that sometimes there is
rainfall
uh this is celebrated as a wonder and we
don't think of things like that and yet
if you look across the world the
problems that we're having today are
Global right so there's it's not as
though these these Traditions have
somehow kept part of the world pristine
so they they've they've lost out to
capitalist forces to to Greed to to all
the other things that we know have
really put us in this place of peril
so does that give you pause regarding
reconnecting with an approach that has
kind of failed I think yes I think we've
got the protests fact don't do any good
frankly we you know I think somehow
we've got to re reignite that that sense
and in parts of the world when I go to
say to Pakistan or India
Ordinary People still have that view of
nature
um of course does it affect their
behavior I mean do you does it go into
practice yes it does but of course the
way the modern societies are now uh
based and that that rather ignores
nature they've they've all taken on uh
Western habits and and that that that is
still there but among the ordinary
people
um and when I talk say in Pakistan and
talk to them about this they their faces
beam and there's a sense of great relief
in the room and certainly in India
that's true in but you see in in uh
Europe and in especially in the
Christian world we never really had that
uh sense of the sacrality of nature
though Thomas Aquinas as I say he did
have it and they but that got lost
and we've now got somehow to to reignite
that and you actually have made
suggestions for from a practical sense
almost a how-to guide yeah of how one
might reconnect uh you know quiet
sitting contemplating you know putting
away your phone every so so but the
question I have there
is do you think that would would be
enough with no it's not but we've got to
make a start somewhere uh because things
are Grim at the moment
um and uh so we we could now we're not
even looking at nature we prefer to take
photographs of it
I mean how often you've seen have you
seen people in the face of great Beauty
going
and and it's the same I spend a lot of
time in the British museum I'm involved
in that and it's the same goes on there
instead of seeing the Rosetta Stone wow
here it is they take about 20
photographs of it and move on to the
next uh installment so we need to start
looking again
and so quite the Chinese for example had
a practice that they call quiet City
and this doesn't mean any huge great
yogic expertise just sit if you start
just for 10 minutes a day
to start with sitting putting away your
phones
and just watching nature for a while
looking at the way the birds are the the
insects the trees the flowers just for
10 minutes a day reconnecting with
nature that we don't even notice anymore
then when you're getting used to that
you could up your uh up your to 15
minutes you know and and take it on that
way but there are other ways to like the
word sacrifice
which we we see the sacrifice between
killing animals in a terrible way in in
a pagan but that that was not the the
word sacrifice comes from the Latin
sacrum Factory to make holy
and uh that what one was asked to do was
to see the it the Holiness that is in
every single thing in that every single
thing every bird every flower
has a particular Beauty a sacrality not
like ours we don't want to sort of uh
impose our Humanity on these things
they're quite different I've got a tree
uh opposite me uh in my study I look up
and I see this tree
uh I live in the middle of London so
there isn't much nature there but I
watched this tree sometimes and
um you see uh how it changes over the
season so the colors change day by day
creatures come all uh and and take
refuge in it different kinds of birds
squirrels Etc there's a whole life going
on there but that tree has an integrity
and life of its own
and I think we've got to learn to see
that the life of things they have their
own Integrity their own life their own
and and recognize that as partners of
the uni in the universe uh not just as
objects
that we can take a photograph of or cut
down or use for our own benefit
somehow we've got to sort of reignite
our sense of reverence and wonder we're
not very good at reverence today we like
being rude to people and
um we don't well I can't say this at the
moment as after the queen shows that you
know the these extraordinary crowds uh
but we need to show reverence for all
people not just uh the queen and not
just important people and not just human
beings
to recognize that there is a different
Socratic in everything and so make a
point of in the day as you see a tree
making it holy in your mind seeing that
it has a different kind of Life a
different kind of preciousness on or
which we depend
because the sense of the Divine
uh it starts with a sense of tremendous
dependence upon the Divine of God and we
now we need to apply that not
necessarily to a god stuck out there in
beyond the universe but it in every
single thing that we see but I'm
wondering if you think if you look at
the
urgency in the situation that we face
right now I just want to get your your
thought on an alternative but resonant
approach to to what you write about and
Frank I only became aware I mean many
people have taken this idea of
connecting you know the state of the
world with our sense of how we connect
to it as individuals but my son actually
who's sitting right there I think of the
lights in my eye you know in his class I
don't know if you're familiar with this
book uh I think the author's name is Roy
Scranton is that a familiar name name to
you I believe the title of the book is
living to die in the anthropocene and it
connects to our earlier conversation
about
death and mortality being a critical
part of how we find our place in the
world because this author is also saying
we've got
a dire situation from climate change and
the only way that we can deal with it is
to not just have ego dissolution at the
level of the individual we have to have
dissolution at the level of civilization
we have to realize that the way we live
has got to change and the the the
reconnecting with reference that you
described would be a vital part but he's
saying we basically have to take a
sledgehammer to the way that we've lived
and smash it to pieces and start again
if we're going to survive as a species
do you feel that kind of urgency yes I
do feel that kind of urgency if I'm not
sure that slashing down a civilization
is going to achieve it because it will
just create anger Fury despair misery
um and and that and all these negative
aspects and instead somehow and we've
got to try and cultivate a more positive
attitude and Forest
uh it but I know it may sound stupid
just start but starting out for 10
minutes a day reconnecting with nature
is at least a start
uh instead of just taking a photograph
of it or ignoring it or trashing it I
mean we we have still in Britain still
people are still leaving huge chunks of
plastic on the beach which we know and
we're told again and again is ruining
marine life but we're still doing it
um so so somehow we've got to make
and it's no good just telling people
what to do because that they get you
know people get antsy about that somehow
we've got to change the way we approach
nature and I think we need have to start
little by little it's no good saying
right from this day forward I'm going to
be a a lover of nature
um that's not going to happen
Wordsworth
um felt like this but poet Wordsworth
English author
um he uh he and his Fred Coleridge were
very worried about the way uh Britain
was becoming more and more mechanically
minded and apart from nature
and he uh he put himself through some
kind of program
and he came what he came out with and
what he describes in one of his poems
uh is exactly what the uh people of
India felt when they thought uh Brahman
when the Chinese saw Chi that not a god
up there but a sacrality he says I have
learned to look on nature not as I did
as a as a young man when he was just
Intoxicated by its beauty but hearing
oftentimes the still sad music of
humanity
No harsh nor Grady
though of ample power to chasten and
subdue
and I have felt a presence that disturbs
me with the joy of elevated thoughts
a sense Sublime of something
far more deeply interviews
whose dwelling is the light of setting
Suns
and the round Ocean and the Living Air
and the blue sky
and in the mind of man
emotion and a spirit that impels all
thinking things
all objects of all thought
and rolls through all things
now that's a perfect expression of what
she what how the how people sought
nature before he has discovered it
within himself and notice he uses the
word something
he won't call it God because God has
come to mean something quite different
for European some being up there in the
sky and uh it's not it's and it is
something that you can't name we use the
word something don't we so so loosely
you know what should we have for supper
tonight oh I don't know eggs or
something but no he said he uses words
something
um and if Wordsworth can do that we can
do it
um but we've got we have to he he would
have put himself he said he's learned to
do it he'd put himself through some kind
of uh program and simply in the my book
I've tried to give a sense of a start it
is only a start but we have to take baby
steps at first
um before so that we could begin to
sense that something
uh that sacredness that is infusing
nature and therefore we will treat it in
a different way
you made reference before really you
know facetiously as a joke to the aliens
looking down upon us and perhaps feeling
pity that neither of our approaches to
the world was adequate
do you I feel confident that when we
make contact with those aliens they will
have some version of the science that we
have found some version of classical
mechanics some version of quantum
account you know some some version of
the scientific ideas that we have
developed in trying to understand
objective qualities of the world
do you have confidence that the aliens
will have their Wordsworth their Buddha
their Jesus their Moses I mean will they
also have this sacred sense will they
have developed that too I would I would
hope so I would think yes I think they
might but they'll be it'll it will be
expressed in very different ways
probably from the way we do
um and because uh their worlds will be
very different from ours in many ways uh
but it I I like to think
that if there are aliens and and other
beings
that they too have got a sense of
reverence for existence for life
uh we know that life is sacred
and we know that human life is sacred
but now we've got to sort of
spell that out to other four other life
forms
and I liked but it would be sacred in an
entirely different way I would think uh
from ours because their brains will be
different from ours they'll see things
differently from us
um they'll have had different
experiences
and
um so I but still I would think in order
that it we cannot live outside our
environment
that's the thing so somehow we have to
come to terms with not only to come to
terms with it but embrace it and
reverence it
and that's what we're not doing anymore
one final question you're absolutely
right obviously we can't live outside
our environment can't transcend our
environment but you made reference
earlier to the power of Mythos and
religion to help us reach a
Transcendence day would you be willing
to share a Transcendent moment that you
had and and how you got there and I know
it's beyond articulation but just to
give us a sense of what it was uh for me
I mean I as I told you I had in the
conference I had nothing of that sort
and it never didn't come through prayer
but for me it came in a footnote
of as a scholarly book
um that said that uh the we must we have
that we are looking at we we cannot uh
understand the spiritualities of the
past from the vantage point of
post-enlightenment rationalism
and that which is what we're often
trying to do
instead we must when we find when the
historian of religion which is what I'm
trying to be find something odd or
peculiar in a in a in a culture
don't just pass over it and say well
this is nonsense of course or this is
just pre-pre-rational or stupid
but
look at all everything around
uh that in that society that was
happening at that time in intellectually
economically uh spiritually uh
environmentally
and not leave it he says until you can
imagine yourself in those circumstances
feeling the same
in this way he said you will begin to
make a place for the other
in your mind and heart now that's what
we've certainly got to do if we want to
make a sense with with other human
beings I mean we're not very good at
that either are we at the moment we've
got somehow to to see that you each
human being where whatever wherever he
or she may be has that utter sacrality
uh and and but we do it by dismantling
our own prejudices and entering in to
the state of another
and I found that that completely changed
my view of religion that was that was
what brought me back to religion uh when
I started studying the religions of the
past instead of saying well this is
rubbish obviously from the point of my
viewpoint entering into that uh that
that society and not leaving it until I
could see in that place I would be the
same I think we have to do that with
nature too
and look uh learn about nature
um see uh the the the
essence of even the smallest bird or
flower or just begin to see it's it's a
Marvel at it
realizing that we share the same
existence
so for me it's a it's a question of
dismantling the self a bit day by day
this uh and entering into other kinds of
lives that other kinds of historical
lives
and so we can learn a lot from the
spiritualities of the past where people
who didn't have our kind of uh Society
still had a reverence for nature
enter into that spirit and realize too
that each thing as has a sacrality at
its core
that however its significance it may be
it is precious we need to look at a bird
or a a and more of butterfly or even a
wasp
and uh and and and
reverence it realize that there's
something there
that we'll never know that is mysterious
to us
uh but precious
just as precious as we are
just one final question
[Music]
are you fundamentally optimistic about
where we are going I can't say that I am
no
um uh but I'm I'm rather a pessimistic
person really I I tend to sort of uh be
but we can't allow ourselves just to
fall into pessimism somehow uh or say
well there's nothing we can do because
unless we try and do something in
however smaller way and however
insignificant away uh nothing is going
to change and it's not and uh our
leaders uh political leaders even our
religious leaders may not be leading Us
in that way it's no good relying on them
we must we each have a responsibility
for the world in which we live the
society in which we live it and it's our
job somehow to change the way we think
and to change so that we begin to
reverence uh the smallest thing uh in
the world around us the vital importance
of humility in the face of the great
Mysteries and knowing that what we know
is a small part of the grander whole is
absolutely essential it's like Einstein
who said who said that you know that
that that
the what the absolute Wonder of knowing
that you are in the presence of
something that is unknowable is what he
regards as God as as the essence of life
we're we're a bit too
omnipotent in our in our unsure of
ourselves and of our of our opinions
when we are all in the dark feeling uh
for what should we be doing now in this
in this
and hoping to find some kind of Truth in
a puzzled world but uh we knowing we'll
probably never never be never
encapsulate that truth yeah Einstein
also says that there are only two things
that he could imagine might be Infinite
Space and human stupidity
and he said he wasn't sure about space
please join me in thanking Karen Enfield
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you